bonjour à toutes et à tous bonne semaine
bonjour jimmy je salue également paul
eric toussaint qui réalise ce matin là
donc notre émission de matinale et puis
bon jour avoue philippe petit bonjour et
un sac à bruges
et oui président de la fédération de lui
des martinique sé l'appellation exacte
invite on dit souvent eu des martinique
mais c'est président de la fédération de
lui des martinis que conseiller
municipal à ducos aussi j'ai été vous
l'avez ces municipales et j'ai
démissionné
vous avez démissionné voilà les petits
bons voeux de santé de dynamisme
courageuse est encore temps on a tout le
mois de janvier pour cette année 2021
bon bien entendu santé à tous les
martiniquais aux auditeurs de l'antique
première mais surtout à tous les
martiniquais dans leur ensemble surtout
dans ces périodes de tristesse
sanitaires alors pour commencer ophélie
petit je vous propose de nous tourner un
court instant vers les états unis
d'amérique
parce que c'est l'actualité nombre de
martiniquais et finalement de citoyens
du monde dont vous peut-être sont
sidérés de ce qui s'y passe là dans
cette période intermédiaire ou joe biden
doit succéder à donald trump joe biden
doit doit entrer en fonction le 20
janvier prochain mais cette transition a
pris une tournure spéciale ces derniers
jours ça se passe en fin de semaine
dernière qu'en pensez-vous avec cette
prise d'assaut en quelque sorte du
capitole du sénat américain
je crois que tout le monde savait depuis
un grand moment que trump était quand
même quelqu'un de particulier et il a
montré par ses communiqués de tweets ses
limites qui ont conduit effectivement
une est une insurrection qui n'avaient
pas de lieu d'être puisque c'était
justement le jour de la validation des
résultats
de l'élection qui le voyait perdant même
s'il avait fait un excellent score
donc je crois que ça pointe la
responsabilité du politique devant des
événements comme ça qui conduisent à la
mort de cinq personnes
oui quand même donc si dramatique et je
comprends que les américains et vous
estimez là qu'il ya une faute grave de
la part du président encore en fonctions
où il donne altran tout à fait et voyez
la parole publique est très délicate et
il ya une faute
effectivement tout le monde le sait
alors la surréaction pas en compte des
réseaux sociaux sur le fait qu'on ait
bloqué son compte twitter
personnellement en tant que démocrate je
suis contre et ça montre quand même
alors sauf si effectivement il y avait
puisqu'il s'était entre temps bien
entendu contre eux dit comme il a
l'habitude de le faire
ça montre qu'il faut quand même avoir
des moyens d'information dans le monde
autre que google est léger américain et
j'espère liberté d'expression de fait
elle est encadrée même même en france je
veux dire vous si vous mettez apprendre
à prononcer à proférer des d incitation
à la haine raciale à la violence
éditorialement pas moi personnellement
mais la directrice ou directeur
publication la direction régionale ici
peut me demander dans la foulée de
couper le micro vous voyez ce que je dis
on a on a la responsabilité éditoriale
j'ai compris tout à fait gueule je dis
qu'il ya quand même encadrée par la
constitution par la loi par la
constitution par la loi tout à fait il
n'empêche que si vous voulez dans toutes
les démocraties puisque c'est le terme
la droit à la parole même s'il est
encadrée doit pouvoir avoir lieu et si
simplement pour rebondir en disant que
nous qui sommes dans le continent
américaine mais avec un statut légitime
européens il faudrait qu en europe y ait
des moyens d'expression autre que google
américain que y ait des géants
dirons-nous européen de l'information
qu'on puisse quand même justement
contrebalancer atténuer vérifier un
certain nombre de données américaines et
c'est ça tout le problème du monopole
une année où philippe petit qui commence
aussi sous le signe du vaccin alors bon
un vaccin pas tout à fait encore
complètement salvateur 1 par rapport à
cette pandémie de de kovy de 19,2 contre
un virus mais qui pourrait tout de même
changer la donne quelque peu sa limite
donc les effets graves de la maladie et
là je m'adresse aux responsables
politiques mais aussi aux citoyens et
aux scientifiques que vous êtes
également qui a exercé la profession de
pharmacien ici alors quel est votre
credo dans cette affaire des vaccins
alors j'ai distribué toute ma vie en
tant que pharmacien maintenant la autre
est à l'origine c'était les vaccin dtp
diphtérie tétanos polio qui
effectivement on éradique et ces
maladies et qu'ils étaient donc qui sont
indispensables
et d'ailleurs on est arrivé maintenant à
11 vaccin ou les gâteaux en pour les
jeunes qui sont pas seulement des trois
qui avaient principaux plus la
coqueluche taille on a donné le dtp est
donc je suis pour les vaccins c'est une
évidence puisque c'est un progrès humain
maintenant il ya une nouvelle technique
puisque avant c'était des virus
désactiver ou atténuées et aujourd'hui à
une nouvelle technique avec la rn
message et c'est toujours le principe
quand on n'a pas assez de recul mais on
ne peut pas nier les progrès de la
science sinon nous n'aurions pas eu des
gens qui vivent jusqu'à 80 5 ans
quatre-vingt dix ans grâce aux vaccins
qui ont été longs et et fait donc je
suis pour la vaccination
maintenant à partir du moment où on n'a
pas attendu la vaccination obligatoire
parce qu'on sait que le virus peut être
mutants c'est le cas de la vaccination
de la grippe
on recommande chaque année mais qu'on
nous oblige pas à faire est bien là je
pense que il ya eu une polémique sur les
passeports de vaccins où je ne pourrais
je ne souhaite pas qu'une discrimination
avec deux populations sur le même délit
alors justement de ce point de vue le
conseil citoyen que
le président de la république lui même a
initié a voulu installer donc le tirage
au sort s'est effectuée et normalement
ce conseil citoyen sur la campagne de
vaccination doit se réunir pour la
première fois le 16 janvier je crois que
c'est ce samedi là qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette initiative d'associer 35
que les hors jeu donnent leur avis
finalement qu'ils soient consultés
écoutez je me demande à quoi sert dans
ce cas les autorités scientifiques c'est
le même possible c'est une réalité ce
qui j'espère la place de tunis gestion
du gouvernement qui à mon avis féfé fait
peu cas de certaines réalités c'est à
dire que les comités qu'on fait en
permanence c'est plus de la démagogie et
de la poudre aux yeux
donc à titre personnel je n'en vois pas
l'utilité permettez même si je salue au
nom mais je la joue je vous assure je
n'en vois pas je voulais juste je
réussissais de ce conseil ne se
substitue pas aux conseils scientifiques
le jeune ya un côté mais je ne comprends
pas le fondement
c'est pour ça qu'en novembre dernier
fait des petits dans un communiqué en
parlant de cette crise qu vide pour
aller vite vous avez intitulé votre
communiqué une administration hors sol
et avouent n'y est pas allé de main
morte un don vous avez critiqué tant
l'état que même la collectivité
territoriale aussi dans la gestion de
cette crise ici en martinique
soyons clairs il ya eu des incohérences
un vrai sens de l'homme tout le monde le
sait dans la gestion de ces crises quand
on vous dit que par exemple vous allez
attraper le virus plus chez vous que
dans les transports en commun je crois
que j'ai vu ça encore aujourd'hui du
ministre du secrétaire d'état aux
transports pour montrer que les
transports sont sion je n'en disconviens
pas mais pourquoi cette phrase si vous
achetez vous attrapez le corps d'un
virus c'est que vous l'avez attraper
quelques prend donc si dany transports
donc ça veut dire que si vous voulez ne
serait-ce que cette phrase de
développeurs il y avait une incohérence
en fait ne serait-ce que cette phrase
d'aujourd'hui du second débat ici on se
parlait hier sélection je vais résumer
le gouvernement je vais résumer votre
propos vous vous allez vous expliquer
sur une minute peut être entre mourir du
coc vie de replier et enfermé sur des
dogmes administratif ou vivre avec les
gestes barrière le temps de
l'acquisition d' immunité collective
vous écriviez lui dé martinique choisi
le bon sens absolument et notamment le
vaccin fait partie de mon sens comme les
tests font partie du bon sens mais il
fallait il faut vivre et ouvrir le
maximum de bac 3 vous avez vu que on a
la martinique
alors qu'on nous a dit hier
l'envahissement des touristes et vous
avez vu que nous restions sont ouverts
je ne comprends pas que dans certains
endroits en france où il n'y a pas
d'avis par des touristes envahissement
des touristes lambda hippies et m ça a
aidé les gens viennent nous visiter
ça a été le terme employé sur les
réseaux sociaux vous pensez bien que non
seulement je suis pour les touristes
pour l'économie martiniquaise mais je
suis aussi pour que nos enfants
reviennent de ce qu'on appelait la
métropole de l'hexagone pour nouveau
prudent il faut rester coup d'oeil à des
gestes barrières mais de la fia des
fermetures administratives deux en
france deux restaurants dans des régions
qui n'ont pas ce que je viens d'appeler
un potentiel touristique énorme comme le
note moi ça me paraît lent connaissent
dieu en plus de se contaminer contenu
delà de la charge virale qui mais qui
sait enfin mais terrasse des salles
clause conférenciers du moment où on ne
fait plus confiance on infantilise les
professionnels parce que on est des
responsables ici on les infantilise je
ne vois pas où est la liberté
et si vous voulez nous sommes dans une
économie administrée qui est une
économie alors qu'ils en auraient cesse
de l'époque il n'ya pas aussi de
centralisme et de peines de liberté qui
a eu dans cette gestion de la crise fait
je le rappelle par des technocrates
sympathique mais hors sol y compris en
martinique y compris de la part des élus
martiniquais parce que voilà on y vient
il nous reste trois minutes
cette gestion de la crise ça fera partie
du bilan viendra présenter les que
j'avais sortante à mallory de l'équipe
s'entraînera toujours se réfugier
derrière le problème des compétences et
ceux qui crient toujours contre le
colonialisme ce sont les premiers à
revendiquer le colon quand il faut au
niveau de la préfecture pouvoir se
cacher donc je ne vais pas faire plus de
commentaires là dessus est finie ah bon
bon alors les comme la campagne des
territoriales est là elle a déjà
commencé hier
enfin le week-end dernier en fin de
semaine le mime a fait sa rentrée et
le président du conseil exécutif qui est
le leader du mime du mouvement
indépendantiste martiniquais alfred
marie-jeanne donc a annoncé qu'il est
candidat à sa propre succession
bon sans grande surprise c'est une bonne
nouvelle et goûtez ça veut dire que les
élus se considère comme possesseur d'un
patrimoine martiniquais
je vous donne un exemple je siège de
chimie que je respecte beaucoup étaient
très tristes d'être battus et de ne pas
pouvoir inaugurer le tcsp d'accord eh
bien monsieur malige nous nous vend
aujourd'hui tu le fait qu' il faudrait
qu'il inaugure le lycée schoelcher donc
il faudrait qu'on le réalise
pour inaugurer le lycée schoelcher voyez
donc je ne lis pas je ne parle pas de
l'âge du capitaine je pense qu'il a
toute sa raison
mais je pense du fait qu'il ya une une
adaptation dans la tête des élus mentez
que pas menti nick setta you le
patrimoine menti ni caisse et ayew alors
qu'ils sont au service de la population
et à produire selon vous je n'ai pas
parlé je n'ai pas voir les beaux dunks
avignon je n'ai pas je n'ai pas produit
résumer à son envie de vouloir inauguré
lycée schoelcher je veux dire que y'a
mais il ya une jeudi à une
on sait ce que vous semblez 10 apery on
avait une eau qui le motive
on a fait une carrière politique a menti
ni quelle qu'elle soit et on est
tellement imbibée de sa fonction qu'on
s'aperçoit pas que la démocratie demande
d alternance et surtout de se détacher
de ne pas en faire une affaire
personnelle
après ne me demandez pas si c'est l'ego
dans l'affectif tous ceux qui font de la
politique ont foncé - négoce sinon il ne
ferait pas de politique jusque là se
mettre à la disposition du peuple
justement comment ça se prépare du côté
de lui des martinique ou même est ce que
vous vous apprêtez à ce que pouvaient
même nous dire ce matin ben ça y est
nous on va on va aller
aux élections de la ctn alors nous on va
faire une liste nous avons fait un
communiqué d'octobre puisque vous avez
dû les communiqués qui indiquait que nos
militants avaient fait un choix le choix
de présenter une liste que nous avons
est utile et ma technique du but où l'on
vous le confirme et là en ce début
d'année alors le 25 janvier bousquet
vous recevez un communiqué nous faisons
nous présente les politiques comme hier
le mime a fait la sienne lui démenti ni
qui lui dit je vais vous dire ce que
c'est que l'unm font leur rentrée
politique à partir de ce moment-là 30
secondes à partir de ce moment là vous
le saurez le 25 janvier mais nos
militants général sont cohérents donc je
pense qu'ils approuveront le principe
que nous faisons en lice pour
représenter une certaine forme
d'alternative d'alternance face aux
indépendantistes phase autonome et aux
autonomistes qui représente le centre à
la vente unique est avec vous en tête de
liste évidemment vous le saurez le 25
janvier merci philippe petit d'avoir
répondu à nos questions bonne semaine
bonne journée à toutes et à tous c'est
moi qui vous remercie